in the lobby of Ramsey solutions at
Jeremy and Deanna are with us hey guys
how are you hey we're doing better than
I deserve welcome where do you guys live
we live in Princeton Illinois fun
welcome to Nashville thank you and here
to do your debt-free screen sir and how
much have you paid off
we paid off ninety thousand dollars and
forty five months and we've also cash
flowed part of my MBA degree during that
for your time good for you
very good and your range of income
during that time we started out ninety
thousand we've gone up from there not
quite doubled that yet but it's true
what you said that you handled God's
money his way he'll give you more to
manage and we've been witness to that
for sure
oh very cool so what kind of debt was
the $90,000 a little bit of everything
we had a 401 k loan a bulk of it was
credit cards probably $60,000 of it we
had car loans student loans a little bit
of everything how long you guys been
married 14 years okay 14 years very cool
so what happened 45 months ago that
changed the direction because you guys
were just kind of normal your be bopping
along and debt like most people yes we
were we had just in 2012 we were at our
10th year anniversary and we were wave
further in debt we wanted to be we
weren't meeting our goals it just will
happen I had a co-worker that gave me
your CDs and I wishing it I listened to
them on the ride home from work and then
I started listening to your radio show
and then I liked your structure of your
program and the steps you had a very
logical god based program and so I let
her finish yeah so he comes home he was
this crazy man on the radio you're like
what are you doing I thought he had you
on iHeartRadio day yeah whenever he came
in the house sound like you were walking
down my hallway
oh no so after a couple weeks of him
being excited let's see it was Christmas
Eve and my heart out is ready for a
change but I didn't know about the
program so I grabbed there getting out
of debt CD and your story really spoke
to me personally since you went bankrupt
that's my story my mom and dad were
farmers and in my early 20s and their
business went sideways
and my parents were my heroes they shall
are and I had an ideal childhood really
American dream and you had to watch them
go through all that pain I did they hit
the wall hard and it was it was
overshadowed our wedding and
overshadowed the birth of our girls and
in November of 2010 it was too much
stress on my dad's part he died of a
heart attack at Pacific know and so I
didn't want my girls to grow up knowing
any kind of fear like that and I never
wanted them to have to witness that with
Jeremy and I so she came down the hall
Dave and she said we're getting out of
debt and we're going to teach the class
whoa
and that really what happened yeah I'm
good
now I got bigger go yeah you're like I'm
not in but I'm in when I'm in I'm in I'm
in alright that's why we talked the
class three times and we helped start
momentum at our local church we're at at
the time and ow yeah well thank you
that's very cool well I mean you've seen
some of the worst possible effects of
that what it did to your mom and dad and
your dad's health and and our
overshadowed what should have been
joyous times in your lives and it does
do that
it does it does rip the guts out of
people's lives and so yeah I can see
that once you believe that this would
work you ain't okay game on
yep and you know and and then you're
going well what have I done I've created
a month yeah I love it that's perfect oh
that's fun so what was the craziest
thing you all did while you're getting
out of debt the thing that people look
at you when you people are nuts
well I could tell you once at one story
I think our old self we had a washing
machine or dishwasher break and what the
same week and our old selves would go
and just automatically buy new and go
down that debt road but you know during
this program had changed us we did the
dishes we went to laundromat for six
weeks ho we saved up it was five months
before I got out a day
rather than building and then your
clothes and even then we didn't go buy
new we got on Craigslist and did that
thing so we still have it today so it's
one of the craziest things we did I
guess Wow
very cool yeah that that's that's pretty
hardcore in this day in time I mean back
when my parents were married you know a
thousand years ago right I mean I going
to laundry that was a way of life trick
you know but now it's it's not it's not
that normal anymore you know and so you
probably had some interesting
experiences doing your clothes there
it's humbling I think we see God through
this whole process but you know God made
sure that we weren't going to feel like
we were getting too big for our britches
and ever in the laundry room yeah yeah
no question about it all right well very
cool you guys very cool I'm so proud of
you what do you give it now that you're
teaching the class you got to start it
everywhere you've done it you paid off
ninety thousand dollars worth of stuff
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of that is I think the
secret is to have have a why you have a
big why and you have a big vision our
family has a vision board we put it up
when we started this journey is still up
today and so have that vision and then
and then do your budgets every it's not
going to happen
life's going to happen to you but just
stick with it yeah you know I got a
friend of mine that grew up really poor
what we call dirt poor which in
Appalachian means dirt floors in the
house right and his wife was to never be
there again and it became a
multi-millionaire in his life working
his tail off and very smart but yeah you
got to have a big wine when I look at
Deana story with her mom and dad and
what good people they are but the
effects of that you it's easy to say
we're changing our family tree not
because they're bad folks because we
don't never never going to happen again
and you broke that cycle forever so
proud of y'all well done that's a great
story one thing I like to say Dave um
the thing that was hardest for me a life
knife is going to happen in the 45
months and and within one year that 45
months we moved to a new town my
grandmother who was very much like a
mother to me as well she passed away
and then my best friend and sister mom
Amy passed away of breast cancer
and so I think it's just to stay focused
on your eye and your vision and and just
give it to God and um and he'll get you
through that and Jeremy gave me a lot of
grace during that time and the intensity
changed a little bit huh and then it
abscent flows depending on that and
those are big events I mean that's not
like oh I want to go out to eat that's a
different deal there I think the ANA our
old selves will go and make big
decisions and to spend money and so that
go through those events and the stay
focused did not go to your old ways was
big for us yeah it's hard but you still
make this you know it's not like you
don't go the funeral but you aren't
driving to the fly or something like
that I mean you make different decisions
while you're while you're in it but you
still make the decisions that are right
and it does change things well
congratulations so you got a copy of
Chris Hogan's book for you getting
signed by him retire inspired number one
bestseller next chapter in your story is
to be completely debt-free and now
become multi millionaire soon so there
we go
when I hear you on the millionaire theme
era now your daughter's names and ages
this is Abby's she's 11 Aleta she's
eight all right very cool all right it's
Jeremy Deana Abby and Aleta $90,000 paid
off in 45 months making 90 to 150 ish
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream oh no I can't fall off forgetting
these things I need to start earning the
apple seeds allure and good to me honey
have a seat
on in 3 2 1
I like it it's fun way to go somebody's
been practicing haha well done well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]